When you're responding to a security
incident, there is undoubtedly going to
be physical and digital evidence that
you'll need to collect. You protect the
integrity of that evidence you're
collecting by creating a chain of
custody. This means that you document
every person who contacts that evidence
in any way. And if there are any changes
to this evidence, we now have
documentation that tells us everyone who
might have made that change. If you're
working with digital evidence, we often
use hashes to have some type of
integrity check that we can use along
every step of the way. If you're
collecting physical evidence, you can
keep it in some type of sealed bag. And
as you can see here, you can write
details about what you have found, and
you have a chain of custody to determine
exactly who came in contact with the
contents of this bag. Digital evidence
often uses digital signatures, so you
can tie back any access to this data to
an individual.
You might also find yourself being the
first response to one of these
incidents. When that's the case, you
should identify what the issue happens
to be. You can do this by checking logs.
You can have in-person information that
you can gather from other folks, and
there may be monitoring data that you
can collect as well. If you've
determined that an actual incident has
occurred, then you can report this
incident to the proper channels. Most
organizations have a list of individuals
who should be directly contacted each
time there's an incident. This is an
important step, especially if this
incident is one that deals with your
local law enforcement group. We need to
make sure that we get those folks
involved as quickly as possible. Your
objective should be to collect any data
that you have associated with this
incident and protect that information
for other people in the organization.
When we're dealing with digital
evidence, we don't usually pick a single
file or single folder and copy that off
to a USB drive. Almost always, we are
taking a copy of the entire drive and
collecting every bit and every bite from
that storage device. This copy process
commonly collects what we call a bit
forbit or a bite for bite copy of that
drive. That means we're not only
collecting the information that we can
see in the files and folders stored in
the file system. We're also collecting
information that might have been deleted
from the drive. Many operating systems
will delete the pointer to a file, but
the actual data of the file is still
stored on the storage drive. That
information only becomes inaccessible if
something is written over that section
of the drive later on. That means if we
perform a bitetobyte copy of the drive,
we really do have an exact duplicate of
that drive stored in an image file. This
allows us to perform extensive analysis
of that data later on without changing
anything on the original storage drive.
This copy is often done with a third
party piece of equipment that you would
connect to the physical drive itself.
That copy device often includes a
hardware write blocker. So you can plug
this in and you know that that device is
not going to be able to remove any data
from that piece of evidence. If you
don't have a physical imaging device,
you could use software imaging tools. So
you might boot this system with a USB
drive and then use software on that USB
drive to copy all of your information
from the internal drive of that system
to a separate storage device or separate
image file. And of course, since we are
collecting digital evidence, we can use
hashes and digital signatures to ensure
the integrity of this information as our
investigation continues.
Something you'll be doing with every
incident is documenting everything that
you did and all of the information that
you collected as evidence. This is not
only important for internal use, so you
know exactly what occurred during that
incident. This might also be involved in
a criminal proceeding. So, you might
need to use this in a court of law. This
documentation might include a summary of
this event itself. This way, you're able
to document what occurred during that
particular time frame while it's fresh
in your mind. As you're acquiring data
from a system, it's important to
document exactly what you did to acquire
that data, including a stepby step of
the process you use to be able to grab
that image or grab that data. If your
job is to analyze the data associated
with this incident, then you'll need to
document everything that you find
associated with this data. This allows
others to also analyze the data and
compare it to your analysis to verify
the information that you found is
accurate. And based on all of the data
that you've gathered, the analysis of
the data itself, you should document
what you feel are the conclusions based
on the information and evidence that
you've gathered.
One of the challenges we have with
computers is that there's a lot of
different types of data inside of our
computing systems. Some of this data
sticks around for a very long time,
whereas other types of data may be gone
in an instant. If it's your
responsibility to collect this data and
evidence from a system, then you'll
probably want to start with data types
that would disappear quickly. For
example, if you think about registers in
a CPU, those registers might change
thousands of times in a second. This
makes it very difficult to collect data
from CPU registers or a CPU cache. We
refer to data that disappears quickly as
more volatile. We refer to data that
sticks around for longer periods of time
as less volatile. For example, an ARP
cache might stick around for 60 seconds
or 5 minutes, but something like a
network topology might rarely change.
Therefore, we can say that an ARP cache
has more volatility than a network
topology. This chart contains just a
sample of the different data types that
you might find in a system. CPU
registers are at the upper level of
being the most volatile. And then we
have router tables, process tables,
kernel statistics, and memory
information just under that level of
volatility. We then can have temporary
file systems which tend to stick around
a little bit longer. And then we have
data that's stored on disk. Remote
logging data and monitoring data tends
to stick around longer than information
we might store on a disk. And things
like a physical configuration or the
topology of your network itself might be
something that rarely changes, putting
it down at the lower levels of
volatility. And if you're putting
information on a backup tape, that
information might stick around for
years. That makes it one of the least
volatile types of data that you might
collect. You can probably think of other
data types that are contained within
your system, and you might want to
consider where that would fit in this
order of volatility.